On poursuit avec : Anie Samson,
ex-mairesse de Villeray-Saint-
de citoyens en action contre
- Bonsoir.
- Vous faites parti de comité
qui demande plus d'action po'acr
faire face à la violence à
Montréal.
- Un comité qui propose des
actions es aux trois
paliers gouvernementaux.
- Ce texte que le ministre vient
me dire c'est que MRS précise sa
demande et on va être là. Comme
si les devants n'étaient pas
assez précises pour qu'il y ait
plus de policiers.
- On a c- On a c- On a c- On a .
On a juste à regarder la
conférence de presse cet après-
midi. 44 minutes de retard.
Probablement quelque chose à
signaler. Pour une situation
aussi importante que la sécurité
de la ville?
On doit être préparée pour ça.
Je prépare à tous les jours.
Depuis un an, ça tire de
partout. J'ose croire que la
mairesse a aussi ses
informations. La conférence de
presse, on entendait des
demandes particulières, précise
que le ministre a dit. On n'en a
pas parlé. Je suiss
quelques semaines du Comer de
policiers on a, combien sont
partis, deux de plus, 42 moins.
On se souvient, pendant la
électorale.
manque beaucoup, 70.
L'chef intérimaire disait
aujourd'hui, on est dans une
phase de retraite.- 40 retraite.
- Est-ce que la mairesse prenne
cette image d'une pas être trop
trop police?
- C'est
dommage, mais oui.
malheureusement, elle traîne
encore ce boulet à son pied, de
toutes ces sorties, les
s encore
appris à lui faire pleinement
confiance. La confiance, se
mérite. Actuellement la façon de
le dossier de sécurité à
traiter, les traiter comme
n'importe quel autre dossier
comme les pâtes, les pistes
cyclables. C'est un dossier, ce
devrait être la priorité àMontr.
- Vous dîtes que la mairesse
manque de leadership dans ce
dossier. Ne sent pas que le
dossier des dossiers.
- Elle n'assume pas le
leadership que devrait assumer
comme maire de Montréal. Un
poste aussi important on est
responsable de la sécurité de
tout lecitoyens.
- Vous avez fait d
recommandations à l'époque.
Concrètement, ce n'est pas que
l'attitude de la mi va
régler ce qui se passe à
Montréal. Vous avez dit que les
policiers puissent faire de
cette ablation plus librement.
Vous donniez l'impression qu'on
les menottait.
- Les policiers, quand on parle
de désengagement, c'est au
niveau des réprimandes qu'ils
peuvent faire. Lorsque celle
d'un véhicule, il s'agit de
communauté. Lorsqu'on parle deen
partant. Ce n'est pas ça.
Lorsqu'une communauté quelle
qu'elle soit ne faite pas sens,t
pas parce que tu ne couleurs de
peau ce qu'on fait du profilage
racial. Actuellement, les
policiers ont peur de le faire
parce qu'ils se disent à partir
du moment qu'on veut arrêter on
se retrouve une plainte en
déontologie.
- On fait quoi?
- Ça revient à
police. Ça revient à mettre des
critères en cause. Ce qu'on
suggérait, c'est d'ajouter des
un listiit
que cette voiture a été arrêtée
trois fois durant la semaine. Il
faut documenter le pourquoi.
Les façons de faire simple
auprès régler plein de
problèmes.
des.
Que le système en général soit
plus sévère. Qu'il n'y ait plus
d'armes de poing.
- Plus que ça. Les armes de
pong,
c'est celle légale.
Celle qui passe par les réserves
indiennes aussi. J'ai rencontré
ministre de la sécurité publique
pour lui parler de refermer les
frontières, mettre de grande
surveillance et l'accessibilité
des armes à Montréal. Le jeune
s'était arrêté avec 250 armes,
la loi faite quoi?
10 mois étaient sortis de
e à
nos jeunes?
- vous êtes en conclusion que la
mairesse aurait dû arriver à
quelque chose de plus structuré
aujourd'hui.
- Oui et plus rassurant.